décideur de poplarville, donc si votre vélo est
bleu à cause de la transparence, je vais couper les
câbles d'accord, faites attention, il
va être soufflé et revenons le
long du bord de l'autoroute, je
veux faire le tour de cette façon, j'encaisse bien
parce que c'était incroyable  sous un grand
bleu il blam chaque fois qu'ils jettent un
méchant c'est que tu as vu finir cette autre
personne c'est cristallin sur la droite ouais
celui-ci a vraiment eu beaucoup de neige
dessus mais j'étais comme quand il est arrivé par
bande pour toujours souviens-toi regarde Lucas regarde
comment il est devenu bleu ressemble à du cristal
existe mais après beaucoup
tu
ok ouvrons la spécification quand je souhaite que ça
aille
allez on va regarder de près ouais encore
un tour de plus autour de l'endroit et
atterrir dessus
ok on y va maintenant te chercher
ok ouais une gorge joker ok pour le
bus mais patron je l'ai eu reste accroché
paires des deux  comme tous les bad blue  e rock
encore une fois
c'est sur nous d'accord on y va on te met aussi content
d'un coup de plus autour de la graisse qu'ils
font face aux gars ici mais pour toi tu travailles
pour moi comment tu es tu connaissais cet
endroit avant de savoir quoi boo comme ça
ouais ouais  à tous ces endroits ici ça le
dépeint aussi ah mais ouais mais pour un
jusqu'à présent mais j'aime bien un pédo même à la
bataille des ionisés des décideurs tout
le temps en vidéo capita estomacs
tombés ici de l'
eau qui vient ici
avoir la grippe
la source est  très très prospère
celui là-bas est ce qu'une pensée
n'était généralement pas pour le reste
oh mon dieu est des yeux pauvres
haha base je change le doigt de filtre atter
it ici et nettoie les voies après eux m
is le péroné euh ouais dans quelques minut
s  Oh Lucas d'
accord et écoutez ces coups
là-bas tête sommes-nous bons pour moi
hé arrêtez
je vous quoi diable d'accord
je oh oh c'est bon alors pouvons-nous arrêter un est
très très bleu quelque part j'oxygène intimement
là-bas allons-y et
incroyable hein
belles 45 prophéties des Ombres  eddakath
est-ce que ça peut vous donner la compétence mais c'est
pour faire une douche que là-dedans en ce moment
bien qu'ils connaissent le paysage la
salle de fitness je me suis trompé mais son
rêve est de sortir aller jusqu'au bout le
premier gars je ne peux pas prolifiquement  boo ok
ouais Carrie on peut se permettre d'aller au
sommet là-bas puis on commence à bouger je
travaille sur le chemin du retour ouais ouais c'est
assez d'obstacle pour y aller Bruno ouais ils
vont vérifier le prochain trimestre puis on a
commencé à travailler sur le sexe je suis calme  hé
arrêtez d'enregistrer le mien est de placer est
incroyable partout d'accord c'est bien
d'avoir du blanc comme ça s'il y a
quelque chose de différent est-ce
que ça paie des salaires si vous ne tournez pas il
y en a encore un gros ok les
gars là en ce moment ok c'est  un très très
bleu d'ici haut mais
je l'ai volé je brancard
si tu peux je le prends tu es trop
ok on revient au putter
Daisy
Oh
je n'essaie pas de trucs de ta mère pense
qu'on va ouais bien mieux de leur part
ok ok retournons au camping-car
ouais  nous allons maintenant il va définitivement
Toto au fait ouais encore nous allons
avant